never have i ever shopped
never have i ever had a threesome wow
hi everyone my name is jun i am an actor
mc comedian
on instagram and i make a lot of short
form comedy skits one thing i do
genuinely love to do
is pair people up i love playing
matchmaker i want to introduce you to
our new series called love lab where i
bring on two contestants and make them
spend
24 hours together on a virtual game you
heard me correctly
24 hours together could i have possibly
tapped into something
could 24 hours be the perfect concoction
to finding the love of your life we'll
see
what's your name hi jun i'm drew hi i'm
drew
i'm 24 now jesus i'm an
animator this is kind of geeky but i
have like a google doc set up just to be
like okay if we run out of activities
what potentially stuff we could do yo
that's kind of romantic
i like that for what i'm looking for in
a partner ideally it'd be
nice to have someone else who's also as
nerdy
geeky as i am definitely someone who's
ambitious hi
hi nice to meet you hi my name is jordan
chan
i'm 21 years old and i am currently
unemployed thanks to
coronavirus what i'm looking for in a
partner in a romantic context
i guess would be somebody who has a good
sense of humor
somebody who's spontaneous and somebody
who's sincere
how's your banter game oh please
hold on i mean i really love getting to
know new people so i'm really excited
but obviously i'm rather nervous as well
but that's just like
that's inevitable first i'll bring in
drew
next we'll bring in jordan well
jordan this is drew drew this is jordan
say hello hi how's it going yo you guys
are
you guys are so nervous without further
ado i'm gonna let you guys
go and your 24 hour starts now
oh my god what's up jordan
nice to meet you too i've been nervous
all the way up to this like
i was talking to june about it but like
i couldn't sleep last night yeah he told
me
obviously we're gonna get to know each
other fairly well i mean 24 hours is a
very long time
you do that there's going to be a lot of
awkward silence it's okay you know we'll
just roll through it like
it's all good
there's the first moment yeah i was
about to say that's the first awkward
silence
hey guy it's me june
are you all getting hungry i think it's
time to share a first meal
show your date what you have in your
fridge i'm going to
eat on my front lawn we're going to have
a virtual picnic
you know what i'm doing
i feel like a weird cooking show now
yeah pretend you're on a cooking show
go so i take these and then put in
some normal uh this quick stuff put in a
little bit of cinnamon
put in some almond milk and then put in
half a scoop away for
wow so healthy master chef over here
sure all right cheers to our virtual
picnic
here i'm gonna go for a coffee run
there's this couple who's like on a date
and they're simping so hard right now
they're both like holding hands like how
do you feel about pda
i'm normally not like a gushy person in
general
i mean like i like rom-coms and rom-coms
i can stand it in real life
it's different i don't know there's a
certain amount of cheese alike yes
have i hit any of your red flags
you listen to edm yeah no i'm just
kidding
not yet hey jordan
how are you i'm okay how are you i've
been
anxiously waiting um how was lunch
uh it was good i had we had a picnic
first impressions i mean he's
he's cool he's he's he seems like a
really chill
dude but i i don't know if like we're
compatible on a romantic level
i feel like she's just as open and
honest and
upfront and like we both can easily talk
about
i guess anything with our lives i don't
know he seems really
easy to talk to he seems really relaxed
and
he's really i don't know i like talking
to him he's like he seems like a really
good guy
i think she's probably a little out of
my league but uh i think it's really
cool
javier which is really pretty
how into uh fashion oh i'm very into
fashion
perfect so i was thinking we could give
each other like themes of like
a fashion outfit or something and we
could be like what's your favorite album
you're so cute
that's so cute i'm so cute
let's do something really loud
okay ooh you look like you're going to
the club it's kind of same vibe though
kind of same vibe
yeah oh my god oh
ooh i love that the shoes are phenomenal
i do the wave a lot you go to a club and
everyone's grinding it's like grinding
so boring like okay
like sure like it's stimulating whatever
sex but like
i want to do like crazy spins and [ __ ]
you know like okay
you have to give me yours too your
instagram feed really reminds me of my
xbox
that's good that was the impression i
wanted to go for oh wow you have like
professional photo shoots
no i don't you're telling me that this
isn't
like professional photoshoot um i think
you're really sweet i don't know you
seem like a very kind person
very very simple person right
yeah you're simply um
i'll i'll go with a very simple response
but um
i think you're really pretty i think
it's pretty dope
i guess hey guys it's me
june it's five o'clock somewhere it's
that time
oh are y'all down for a happy hour drink
up
hell yeah i'm gonna give you the choice
of what i'm gonna be drinking tonight
tequila
cheers cheers clink never have i ever
gone to work
high never have i ever
chopped never have i ever had a
threesome
wow i'm a little tipsy so i'm not sure
i think it's approaching hour seven the
more i talk to him the more i like him
it's cool i i feel like we're really
getting to know each other on a deeper
level
of course we're only like a fourth of
the way through this 24-hour date so
i think you should give me a list of
three possible friends or you can even
just give me one friend
and i'm gonna call that friend put
myself on mutes and ask them to describe
you to me
awesome okay
hello hi maria this is uh drew this is
the
random dude that jordan just told you
about i figured
i'd give you the chance just to tell me
about jordan
[Music]
um
he's just nodding i don't know what that
means
cool uh thanks maria i appreciate you
taking this random ass call
cool
i want you to tell me why he would be
a good person to date and also why he
would not be a good person to date
um
in terms of like his bad size i mean
he's like super stubborn
like my gosh what are you talking about
pretty funny uh pretty funny kind of
funny
okay thank you amber it was nice
chatting with you
that was interesting that was fun and
also nerve-wracking
wow hi what's your name i'm jordan
hi victoria nice to meet you guys
okay i dare you to do your makeup or
have your
oh my god have your girl roommate do
your makeup yeah
can i give you some inspo i only have
eyeliner
and mascara but go for it oh you don't
have any eye shadow or lipstick
uh i might have i have some lip gloss
maybe
pop that sucker out
[Music]
and this is the finished look amazing
incredible
and i want you to put on some uh scene
style makeup
yeah like raccoon eyes i told you i will
do any dare
[Music]
this is so bad
[Music]
he doesn't have fragile masculinity
which is
like yeah he's not afraid to
you know look like a fool and goof off
we've matched up a little bit with our
sense of humor which is nice and we can
actually banter back and forth which i
think is important
i i think i'm pretty compatible with her
we'll see how she feels about me
okay making pb j hey
skippy's skippy cheers
so we said a romantic dinner so we gotta
have a candle if there's a romantic
dinner
all right i'ma light some candles too
who or what
might have stopped you from realizing
your full potential
oh [ __ ] we're going deep we're always
our own worst enemies
we're we're always our you know worst
critic so i feel like the person who
holds me back the most is me
is there a specific moment where you
feel like you held yourself back
there have been myriad times in my life
where i've
not taken advantage of opportunities
presented
for me because i'm like uh you're not
good enough to do that anyway
might as well not even try you know what
about you this is like
it's kind of oddly specific but it's
like a moment in sixth grade where i
kind of began
more focusing within myself and not
being as social
so i feel like if i had a little more
of that time to be able to socialize and
learn it would have helped a lot
later years where i wasn't as i guess
socially developed or
was more socially awkward and had to
learn when everyone else said oh i
figured out
social cues and all that kind of stuff
how are you feeling i mean i'm honestly
pleasantly surprised because
i really thought there would be more
awkwardness but it's been
really organic conversation so you guys
drank a little bit
did you guys get tipsy at all yeah i got
drunk
you got drunk okay did it go up a few
points
well yeah you know what the more i talk
to him the more i like him
it seems like you know from our previous
talk you've loosened up a little bit
are you saying i was uptight before no
no no
come on give him a little bit of a
chance give him a little bit of love it
and it seems like
you know it seems like you have so i'm
just i'm just i was open-minded
do you find yourself a little more
attracted to her just as a person or
romantically yeah i mean i i think from
the get-go i said in my diary that i
think she's
uh insanely pretty um insanely
oh look at you're such a gentleman yeah
and uh
honestly a little out of my league but
uh yeah wow
well just don't let that show man
here's my pitch scott pilgrim
every time we laugh we have to drink
okay
ready okay
all right three two one
go
[Music]
i know all the lyrics
we're about to do a virtual room door
the door
the towel
my mirror my bucket hat
my keyboard case my raisin brand my
knitting supplies my vinyl records my
photo albums
my books hey bulba tour yeah
all right my door vr headset first
closet
all filled with all of my crazy
button-ups that i have
this uh is definitely a deal breaker for
a lot of people
this is my pet i've had since i was
six and he's grown up with me so he's
definitely kind of
inessential this is my snake oh my god
rosie i totally forgot he had a snake
yeah so how do you feel about snakes i
guess is my question
i mean i don't
like i don't really have an opinion on
them i guess
cool like like they're cool
but yeah i'm not crazy
can you take your snake out you want me
to
[Music]
you're an interesting fellow
[Music]
buddy oh my god
[Music]
oh my god that's so weird it's like
hour one through twelve yeah this dude's
pretty normal
hour 13 what the did i get myself into
i i'm going to admit it i'm a very
difficult person to date
so i have major clinical depression
and so i know that's obviously
a difficult thing to tackle when you're
dating somebody so usually when i have
depressive episodes
i tend to retreat i don't like asking
other people for help
unfortunately i'm exactly the same way i
mean
obviously i don't i can't connect with
you on clinical depression
i think i have my own depression i
definitely have anxiety
but uh when i have a problem or issue i
get really dark
like i like get off the grid and like
completely want to handle it by myself
and it's like i don't want anyone else
trying to come for me and talk to me
draw each other or a picture that you
think represents the other person
this is you with your eyeliner your
mascara and your spiky hair
this is you riding your pet lizard into
war
it took you that long to draw that shut
up i told you i'm bad at trying
there was one day i was really craving
me
i didn't have anything to eat the
mayonnaise with
so i ate the mayonnaise with the
goldfish
what a combination how did it taste
first of all
not good and like as we went on i was
able to
back pedal away from that and tear down
the wall a little more
i don't really see the purpose in trying
to
put on a mask and like pretend to be
this perfect ideal version of myself or
what a man expects a woman should be
what hour is this it is almost 3 a.m
what is that hour
17.
uh i don't know
okay if you believe hard enough you can
walk on the water
and me being like a 10 year old kid i
was like well that's dope like
i can walk on water if i just believe in
jesus
but when i was a kid that story freaked
me
out especially when you're okay you're
much more susceptible to all the scary
stories
[Music]
hour 21
hour 21 what are your bad habits
staying up 24 hours
[Music]
going out on our stranger is virtually
for
24 hours straight the only cereal i will
eat
is raisin bran i refuse to eat any other
cereal that's a good
cereal i'll give you that
jordan
jordan
you are so close
gotta stay up i am you're literally so
bundled up right now
it's cute but also like you're falling
asleep
oh i'm not
is it star wars what is that harry
potter harry potter
harry potter harry potter harry potter
i don't know anything about harry potter
you fool
take one i am
exhausted i don't recall anything we
talked about this past hour
i've had a fun time so far it's it's
felt i mean it's been
exactly a day but it's felt more than a
day
it's like we've gone through multiple
different phases of ourselves
man i'm tired i'm i'm so tired
hello jordan jordan you there
good morning
so how was how was your night super
tiring by the last two hours we
or the last three hours we were both so
exhausted we weren't even really talking
we were just kind of like rambling
were there any sparks on your end
the more i talk to him the more i like
him like i like him
he seems really chill and he's very
i don't know really nice he was
a delight to hang out with
i don't think that this is going to
necessarily blossom into anything
like a relationship now that it's been
pretty much a full
24 hours how do you how do you
feel do you feel differently do you feel
the same
yeah i mean i feel like my first
impression has stayed pretty consistent
i i like her a lot
um really cool really cute really
awesome
general all-around great person i think
we have a lot of uh good similarities
but also
as we were saying i think i think we
have a lot of good differences as well
um and i think both are important
so if i were to offer you guys
a second date everything paid for both
parties have to
go in knowing and agree that this is
kind of a romantic second date
would you take that yeah 100 i'd
definitely like to go on a second date
with her
would you go on a second date
romantically
you can be straight up he there's
nothing wrong with him like
i'm just like i don't he's so simply
like
hey what's wrong with that what if he
what if he treats you well you know
it's just not my type like okay if i'm
hearing you correctly
is that a no can't
be romantic in a casual sense
okay okay so jordan here's my pitch
i'd like to go on a second date with you
i'd like to go somewhere we can meet in
person
so i was thinking we could get coveted
tests
we could go uh after that go
on a hike or nature somewhere angela's
forest
watch the sunset or whatever just simp
out
how do you feel about that am i going to
date with me or not could we do
a social distance
sure yeah okay
cool yeah is it weird asking somebody on
a date in front of other people
very weird chemistry is that chemical
and emotional interaction that two
people have
and it's just there you can't really
pinpoint it and when you feel it
you know it's genuine drew seemed a
little bit more consistent
jordan on the other hand i don't know if
she was really feeling him
romantically am i not to say that sorry
true not bad
will they go on a second date was there
chemistry there
who knows until next time we'll see you
thank you for tuning in to love love
i'm just so uncomfortable i mean i'm
through this right now
i am fully clothed thanks ma'am
uh we're on our second date here as i
pitched
we went to the beach waiting for uh
sunset and i'm about to jump in the
water which is why
i'm shirtless